fantastico ed ho visto un sacco di video
per tanti anni e quindi sono onorato di
essere qui
diciamo che quando sono stato invitato
qui ho avuto un pochino di problemi a
cercare di capire come inviare il
messaggio unendolo al tema fondamentale
del teteks le nuvole beh diciamo che ci
ho pensato un po ma poi tutto sommato ho
pensato a me io passo la maggior parte
del mio tempo tra le nuvole a sognare
ognuno di noi sogna in questo momento
ognuno di noi sogna qualcosa però la
cosa importante non è quello che
sogniamo adesso ma quello che sognavamo
da bambini da dove iniziò tutto bene
tutto è iniziato da sogni classici di
bambini io da piccolo sognavo quello che
forse sognano tutti i bambini di fare il
pilota pilota di aereo di macchina
l'idea era quella di andare nello spazio
quindi di di cercare di varcare le
soglie che tutti noi sogniamo di mercati
e allora perfetto percorso delineato
scuola quella non manca mai
accademia accademy aeronautica si va in
accademia pilota di vento pilota diventò
pilota il lavoro tanto faccio tanto il
pilota vado avanti lo spazio perché è
quello il sogno andare sulla luna vele
nello spazio perfetto è fatta
no non è andata proprio così altrimenti
forse oggi vi parlerei dalla stazione
spaziale con tarantino nello spazio
sulla stazione spaziale fantastica vabbè
però andiamo avanti non è andata così
ripartiamo questa slide
si intitola si riparte follia network
perché delle volte per ripartire serve
un po di follia
bisogna avere la spinta io ho avuto la
fortuna di averlo in casa il mio papà
dopo vent'anni di italsider ilva ha
deciso di lasciare l'ilva è mettersi in
proprio aprire il suo studio tecnico
dopo vent'anni quindi di progettazione
meccanica risoluzione di problemi si è
messo in proprio e ha iniziato a
collaborare con un'azienda grandissima
qui non si possono fare nomi un'azienda
grandissima che però passava a noi
solamente problemi strani irrisolvibili
cos'è rognose e quindi noi abbiamo
iniziato ad allenare il cervello la
ginnastica cerebrale nel cercare di
risolvere problemi strani rapidamente è
iniziato a lavorare e generare network
di persone di aziende ero ancora
giovanotto dopo le scuole superiori
quindi iniziato tanto tanto nei pof e
poi man mano creato il mio network
network di persone di aziende e poi
crescendo ti accorgi che il network deve
nascere per prima cosa in famiglia è lì
parte tutto perché tu devi trovare le
persone folli vicino a te quindi si crea
il network si cresce si va avanti e poi
pian piano cresce e si estende alla tua
città della tua famiglia passi alla tua
città
cresci cerchi di spostare il network poi
all'italia e perché no al mondo tanto
adesso è facilissimo adesso chissà ci
vedranno da chissà quante parti del
mondo non basta bisogna crederci per
davvero
perché quando hai creato il tuo network
e ai tutto intorno a te e si sta tutti
quanti vicini a cercare soluzioni a
parlare a discutere ma ci devi credere
ci devi credere perché devi trascinare e
farti trascinare dal suo gruppo
questo è sicuramente uno dei compiti più
difficili ma allo stesso tempo più
semplici sede nel network persone che la
pensano come te che sognano come te che
sognano che hanno la testa fra le nuvole
beh poi se ci si crede ovviamente tutto
è concesso
puoi sfidare la gravità questa immagine
è importante lo puoi fare poi alteranti
ma anche questo non basta bisogna andare
avanti e cercare strade differenti
soluzioni differenti cercare di non
stare sulla stessa scia tracciata da
qualcun altro
quindi trovare soluzioni diverse e non
imporre al tuo tempo alla tua squadra le
soluzioni che poi tu vorresti attuare
perché ognuno ogni elemento della
squadra deve essere libero assolutamente
quindi non bisogna arrendersi al di
solito facciamo così perché quello è
l'inizio della fine
facendo così portando avanti così la
nostra attività sicuramente riusciremo a
trovare tutte quante le soluzioni in
tempi più rapidi soluzioni differenti
daremo sfogo alla fantasia e cercheremo
di non stare sulla sul solco tracciato
da qualcuno gli stereotipi le solite
idee o una figlia femmina le faccio fare
danza classica ma magari se se lei
decide a ma qualche altra cosa
magari si esprime al meglio suono della
batteria tutto questo discorso e per
serve per arrivare a quello che poi è il
cuore di tutto quanto l'osmosi delle
soluzioni che cosa strana osmosi di
soluzioni significa che alla fine noi
cerchiamo di trovare le soluzioni e
seguiamo un metodo che è quello del
sistema engineering facciamo una slide
un pochino più tecnica ma parliamo di
system engineer il sistema engineering
in realtà basato su dei concetti
generati dall international council on
sistema engineering lin cose ci dicono
una cosa abbastanza semplice complicata
dal tuo tema abbastanza semplice che è
quella di prendere un problema grande e
smembrarlo in tanti problemi piccolini
quando riusciremo a fare questo
riusciremo a trovare anche la soluzione
ad ognuno di questi problemi piccolini e
ci tornerà a semplice spostare la
soluzione del problema in altri ambiti
quindi io definisco tanti piccoli
problemi ne trovo le soluzioni
modalità che abbiamo detto prima con
passione sognando poi questa soluzione
al problema sarà mia io potrò
scontornare le condizioni al contorno e
questa sarà la mia soluzione e potrò
quindi applicare altre regole del
sistema engineering quello si chiama vi
model in questo mondo che ci permettono
di definire specifiche di tirare fuori
requisiti e di andare fino in fondo nel
processo produttivo ma ricordiamoci sì
abbiamo fatto trovato tante soluzioni
cellulari riusciremo a costruire
un'altra soluzione più grande in un
altro ambito complicata diciamo che alla
fine mi direte ok fabio bello ma qualche
diciamo qualche esempio pratico ce
l'abbiamo
proviamoci sistema robotico sistema che
fa abbinamento quindi controllabile
tramite un'interfaccia con un computer
di missione dotato di un'autonomia di un
intelligenza
questo sistema riesce a evitare gli
ostacoli a cercare eseguire la sua
missione a collaborare in champ e quelli
ad esempio di tanti robot che
collaborano tra di loro
ok dove vogliamo applicarlo fabio dove
che possiamo trasportare questa
situazione che sembra ormai cucita su
questo problema su un sistema medicale
sì perché una sedia rotelle che riesce a
interfacciarsi con un oggetto che si
chiama b sia i brain computer interface
in grado di sentire le onde cerebrali di
un malato di sla porterà a termine la
sua missione in autonomia dove la
missione magari non è cercare le bombe
ma evitare gli ostacoli con lo stesso
sistema che abbiamo installato sul robot
altro esempio sistemi medicali quindi
manteniamo il medicale facciamo il
percorso inverso sistema medicale che in
grado di rilevare alterazioni con un
oggetto chiamato termocamera quindi
rilevare surriscaldamenti superficiali
bene questo oggetto mette di rilevare
infiammazioni ma in altre applicazioni
ci permette di conoscere delle
temperature che ci sono utili per
valutare lo stato di usura di un oggetto
quindi medicale sembrava tutto
assolutamente cucito li meccanico racing
sistemi avionici sistemi di collaudo di
ori di aerei piuttosto che sistemi
veramente complessi con rotazioni
elevatissime coppie elevatissime su
giochi giocattoli smart mobility non
solo giocattoli ma sistemi di mobilità
sostenibile quindi spostiamo
dall'armonica sembra strana passiamo da
un aereo a uno skateboard e poi sistemi
di taglio laser che ci permette di
tagliare ad altissima velocità prodotti
in linea ma il a cosa può servirci anche
beh io direi che un laser può anche
servire a generare emozioni come le
genera
[Applauso]
[Musica]
quindi cosa è successo a per ragazzino
che all'inizio aveva tutti quei sogni
beh alla fine non ha proprio volato però
ci si è avvicinato a quel mondo e quindi
che cosa possiamo fare ricordiamoci
quest'ultima slide continuiamo a sognare
continuiamo a tenere la testa fra le
nuvole facciamo rete
uniamoci dobbiamo farlo e poi proviamo a
fare osmosi di idee
proviamo a risolvere i problemi non
immaginiamo ai problemi come grandi
risolvibili spezzettiamo li risolviamo
ii e portiamoli da un'altra parte
chiudo con una frase che non è mia ma i
di albert saint george che e le persone
che ha scoperto la vitamina c
grazie alla quale prima si moriva di
scorbuto adesso la vitamina c ci ha
aiutato in tanti in tanti ambiti
beh lui diceva che anzi vi prego di
andare a ricercare albert senso di sé ea
guardare come ha fatto a scoprirla
vitamina c
lui diceva che la scoperta consiste nel
guardare la stessa questione come fanno
tutti ma pensare a qualcosa di diverso
proviamoci
[Applauso]